with distance learning separating so
many students from their teachers one
candidate for national teacher of the
year
worries that some may fall through the
cracks because it almost happened to him
missouri p.e teacher darian cockrell
says educators saved his life and that
inspired him
to help a new generation of students
build up their minds
and bodies errol barnett shows us he's
against the odds journey
to success
[Music]
it's easy to see why mr dc as his
students call him
was named missouri's teacher of the year
who is the most popular teacher in
school
mr d.c but some students at crestwood
elementary school nissan lewis was
surprised to learn recently
mr dc used to go by a much different
name
six deuce 87 kitchen [ __ ] gangster
yep your 2021 missouri teacher of the
year used to be in a gang
a gang he joined at just nine years old
in this north st
louis neighborhood that's 15 minutes and
what seems like a world away from the
suburban school
where he teaches today i felt like i was
born just to fail
like my mother was a drug addict my
father was murdered when i was four
years old
cockrell felt destined for that fate or
jail
this is actually where my little brother
was murdered
early on cockrell's grandmother swooped
in to save him man i just
i feel sorry for my grandmother because
she had to put up with so much
we need to have mr dc's who can help us
and support us
and get us through those tough times and
she did everything by herself
sorry eventually school and sports
became his refuge
in eighth grade he was adopted by his
football coach
no i am not michael orr from the blind
side
although i did have dreams of the nfl
but he was more
inspired by educators so cockrell became
a teacher
landing here at crestwood elementary
school how did you get to crestwood
i took a cab
that laughs makes the fun infectious in
his classes
whenever you're sad he cheers you up how
can a teacher tell when
students are sad i have no idea it's a
magical power
he teaches us how to stay healthy and
have fun at the same time
something cockrell shares online in
workout videos with his three-year-old
son
dawson now cockrell is competing to be
national teacher of the year okay so
perfect he's only been an educator for
under a decade
but in reality mr dc brings a lifetime
of experience
i've seen so many bad things and i'm
just so happy that i'm alive
that i have a job that i love so if
people are tired of me laughing
being positive and giggling all the time
they're just going to get used to it
[Laughter]
for cbs this morning i'm errol bonnett
can we vote for teacher of the year mr d
can we vote does that count oh my god
i sure wish you sure i love what the
girl said when she's when she said how
did cow does the teacher know when a kid
sat and she said i have no idea it's a
magical magical sister
but about learning and having fun at the
same time you like
everything about him i also love that
he's a pe teacher p is the thing that
people forget about and
when there's budget cuts it goes first
to p e p e matters and he's showing why
he doesn't say it again i say it every
time one great teacher can change your
life
and they do every single day